Today I have the impossible task of finishing,
uh,
the,
the parts of the republic that I have assigned for the class.
And,
uh,
in the past,
sometimes I've assigned a full two weeks to the republic,
which would be four lectures.
Uh,
but because I wanted to do some other things with the course as well,
I had to cut the republic by one lecture and now I'm,
I'm paying for that today.
So I'm going to try to rush through unfortunately a number of the major themes,
uh,
regarding the creation of the just city creation of color.
And then,
uh,
try to end the class by talking about,
as I like to do for every thinker.
Uh,
what does in this case,
what does,
what does Plato,
what are his views on modern America?
What does Plato say to us today?
But I want to start with what is one of the grand themes of the republic.
It is indicated in book two,
uh,
by Eddie and manages his speech about self control.
It has introduced further by the claims of the,
uh,
of Socrates to control a,
to sensor,
to control the poetry and the arts,
uh,
of the city.
And this is the big theme of what one might call the control of the passions.
Uh,
this is the theme of every great moral list from Spinosa to con to Freud.
How do we control the passions?
And it is certainly a large theme of Plato's theory of Justice in the republic.
Every great moral philosopher has a strategy for helping us submit our passions
to some kind of control to some kind of supervening moral power.
And again,
recall this is the theme raised,
uh,
at the beginning of book two,
by adding Mantas who puts forward an idea of self control or what he calls self
guardianship,
uh,
as his goal,
how can we protect ourselves from the passion for injustice?
And one of the things Socrates emphasizes,
uh,
is that the most powerful of those passions is the most powerful passion,
is the,
is that Socratic passion that he calls Thumos,
uh,
or what our translator has his spiritedness anger.
Uh,
maybe what the,
what Biblical translators call heart,
uh,
having,
having a big heart,
having thumos.
And all of that implies this is for Plato,
the Political Passion,
uh,
par exsalonce.
It is a kind of fiery love of fame,
love of distinction that leads men and women of a certain type,
uh,
to pursue their ambitions in public life in the public space.
Uh,
it is clearly connected.
This notion of spirit had nurse or this through Motak quality to our capacities
for her heroism and for self sacrifice,
but it is also connected to our desires for domination and the desire to
exercise tyranny over others through most has a kind of dual component to it.
It can lead us to a sense of kind of righteous indignation and anger at the site
of injustice,
but it can also lead us in a rather contradictory way to desire to dominate in
tyrannized over others.
This is the quality that,
that Socrates regards as being possessed by every great political leader and
statesman.
But it is also clearly a quality possessed by every tyrant and the question
posed by the republic in many ways.
The question around which the book as a whole,
uh,
gravitates,
is whether this through Mautic quality can be controlled.
Can it be redirected?
Can it be rechannel in the service of the public good?
Socrates introduces the problem of the most,
uh,
by a story,
a particularly vivid story that I hope you will remember.
We're in book four.
He tells the story about Leon ts at the balls.
Leontief he writes,
was proceeding from the Pi radius outside the north wall when he perceived
corpses lying,
you're the public execution.
At the same time,
he desired to see them.
He wanted to see this grotesque site,
these,
these dead bodies lying there.
And to the contrary,
he felt disgust and turned himself away.
And for a while he battled with himself and hid his face,
but eventually overpowered by desire.
He forced his eyes open and rushing toward the corpses said,
see you damned wretches take your fill of this beautiful site for 39.
See
that story that Socrates tells here,
uh,
is not one of reason controlling the passions,
but rather one of intense internal conflict that Leon ts felt.
Uh,
we see his conflicting emotions both just see and not to see a sense that,
uh,
he wished to,
to observe.
And yet he is at,
in some ways at war with himself knowing to Goc to stare at this site.
There's something shameful about it.
And he felt shame.
One example I particularly like of this was suggested,
uh,
last year I think by Justin's RMB who said,
it's the,
it's the emotion we all feel when we're driving down the highway,
right?
And we see a car crash or we go buy a wreck in.
Everybody slows down,
right?
They all want to see what are they hoping to see?
Well,
they want to see blood.
They want to see if there's a body.
They want to see how much damage has been caused.
And we all,
we've all been in this where we know that it's shameful to,
to look at this.
Just this drive on mind you is Socrates would say mind your own business.
And yet at the same time,
we,
we feel even against our will compelled to,
to look and think of it.
Think about that.
Uh,
and think about that and that this case of Leontief was,
uh,
the next time you'll,
for those of you who have driver's licenses,
uh,
no,
the next to,
uh,
who drive driving on the highway and see something like that.
It is the thumos that is the cause of it.
Should,
that should be the cause of your shame at slowing down to look.
Sometimes we can't help but slow down because everybody is slowed down in front
of us.
We have no choice.
But anyway,
that,
that incident,
uh,
that story that Socrates relates is connected to the fact that Leante has a
certain kind of man.
He is,
he,
he regards himself as proud,
independent,
someone who wants to be in control of his emotions but,
but isn't a,
he has a soul at war with himself and potentially therefore at war with others
in the room.
With the republic tries to do is to offer a strategies,
maybe even we might even call it a therapy for dealing with through most,
for submitting it to the control of reason and helping us to achieve some level
of balance of self control and moderation.
And these are the qualities taken together that's talk with these calls,
justice that can only be achieved when reason is in control of the appetites and
desires.
The,
again,
a question the book asks is whether that ideal of justice can be used as a model
for politics.
Can it serve as a model for justice in the city?
Uh,
this connection we,
he is established between justice in the city and justice in the soul.
What are the therapies or,
or strategies for solving,
uh,
injustice in the soul or imbalance of some kind in the soul?
Can those be transferred or translated in some way to public justice,
to two political justice,
justice and in the Polis,
right.
You,
you with me on that?
So far?
So on the basis of this,
uh,
Socrates proposes how to proceed with the construction of Calypso lists and he
does so through what he calls three waves.
There are three waves that will three waves of reform,
so to speak,
that will contribute to the creation of the city.
The first of these waves is you remember the restrictions on private property,
even the abolition of private property,
the second the abolition of the family,
and the third wave being the establishment of the philosopher kings.
Each of these waves is regarded as in some way necessary for the proper
construction of adjust city.
And I'm not going to speak about all of them,
but I do want to speak a little bit about because it has particularly particular
relevance for us.
Uh,
his proposals for the coeducation a of men and women.
That is a great part of his plan,
especially related to the abolition of the family that men and women be,
uh,
educated in the same way.
Right?
The car of sacrifices,
proposal for equal education,
uh,
is
presented in a,
in a context that he knows to be or suggests will be laughable.
It will certainly be seen that way.
He suggests by Glaucon and Eddie Amanda's there is no job.
He states it cannot be performed equally well by both men and women.
Is Socrates a feminist
gender differences?
He says there are no more relevant when it comes to positions of political rule
then is the distinction between being bald and being Harry.
Socrates is not saying that men and women are the same in every respect he says,
but equal worth respect to competing for any job at all.
There will be no glass ceilings in Calypso lists.
Uh,
first in many ways.
Great defender of the first grade champion of the emancipation of women from the
household.
But this proposal comes at certain costs.
He tells us the proposal for a level playing field demands of course equal
education.
And here he says that men and women being submitted to the same regimen will
mean a among other things that they will compete with one another in
coeducational gymnasium.
They will compete with each other in the nude because that is the way Greeks
exercised.
They will,
they will compete naked
in a coeducational gymnasium.
I think.
Think of that.
Okay.
Furthermore,
their marriages and their procreation will be,
he tells us for the sake of the city,
there is nothing like romantic love.
Uh,
among the members of the Guardian class,
sexual relations will be intended purely for the sake of reproduction and
unwanted fetuses will be a boarded
only exception to this prohibition is for members of the Guardian class who are
beyond the age of reproduction.
He tells us,
and today he says,
can have sex if they're still able,
uh,
with anyone.
They like a kind of version of recreational sex as a reward for a lifetime of
self control.
Child bearing may be inevitable for women,
but the rearing of the child will be respond,
will be the responsibility of the community.
Uh,
or at least a class of guardians in common daycare centers.
Sort of variation of Hillary Clinton's book that it takes a village
to raise a child,
comes right out of Plato.
Apparently no child should know their biological parents and no parent should
know their child.
The purpose of this scheme being to eliminate senses of mine and me to promote a
kind of common sense of esprit de Corps among the members of the Guardian Class,
a community of pleasure and pain.
Uh,
Socrates calls it at four 64,
eight a what we are creating is a community of pleasure and pain.
I will feel your pains and of course you will.
You will feel mine.
The objections to Socrates are of course,
you know,
raised as early as is by Aristotle himself and the,
in the very next generation.
Uh,
how can we care for things?
How can we truly care for things that are common?
Uh,
we learn to care for things that are closest to us that are in some way our own.
We can only show proper love and concern for things that are ours.
Not,
not things that are common.
Common ownership,
Aristotle argues will mean a sort of common neglect.
Children will not be raised,
uh,
better by,
putting them under the common care of Guardians of,
of,
of guardians or in daycares,
but they will be equally a neglected.
Yeah,
but it in this,
and you can think about that,
but whether that's true or not,
but it is in the same context of his treatment of men and women,
did something else often goes unnoticed.
And that is Socrates is efforts to rewrite the laws of war.
Because of course,
the guardians are being trained and educated to be,
to be guards,
to be warriors,
to be members of a military class in the first place.
He tells us,
children must be taught the art of war.
This must be the beginning of their education.
Socrates says,
making the children's spectators of war.
Okay,
children love will be taken.
He seems to suggest two battles and two sites of where we're fighting is going
on to be spectators,
uh,
for them to become use to in,
in,
in a bitchy,
waited to seeing war and everything that goes on.
Not only his expulsion from the ranks of the Guardians,
a penalty for cowardice,
but Socrates suggests there should be listened to this erotic rewards for those
who excel in bravery,
erotic rewards for excellence in bravery.
Consider the following.
Remarkable proposal it for 68 C and I add to the laws of war.
Socrates writes it as long as day.
Uh,
the guardians are on campaign,
no one whom he wants to kiss should be permitted to refuse so that if a man
happens to love someone,
either male or female,
he would be more eager to when the rewards of valor.
Okay.
It is to say as a reward for bravery,
exhibited bravery,
the hero should be allowed to kiss any one day like while they are on.
Okay.
Patrol male or female,
uh,
particularly puritanical editor of Plato from the 20th century writes in a
footnote to that passage.
This is almost the only passage in Plato that one would wish to blot out.
His sensibilities are offended by this notion,
but I wonder what kind of,
if this might even make a powerful incentive for military recruitment today.
Okay.
What do you think?
Well,
think about it.
I don't know.
So at long last we moved from the education of the guards to justice.
What is justice?
We've been question.
We've been asking ourselves do out this book and which Plato has been,
Socrates has been teasing us with at long last we come to this thing,
the platonic idea of justice concerns harmony.
He tells us both harmony in the city,
in harmony,
in the soul.
We learned that the two are actually a homologous in some way.
Justice is defined as what binds the city together and makes it one or he puts
it another way.
It consists of everyone and everything performing those functions for which they
are best equipped.
Each of the other citizens,
Socrates says,
must be brought to that which naturally suits him,
which naturally suits him.
One man,
one job he says so that each man practicing his own,
which is one will not become many,
but one.
Thus you see,
he says the whole city will naturally grow up together.
Justice seems to Maine,
it adhering to the principle at least justice in the city adhering to the
principle of division of labor.
One man,
one job everyone doing or performing the task that naturally fits or suits them.
One can of course is you've already imagined raise several objections to this
view.
And again,
Aristotle seems to take the lead.
Plato's excessive emphasis on unity would seem to destroy the natural diversity
of human beings that make up a city is their one and only one thing that each
person does best.
And if so,
uh,
who could decide this was such a plan of justice not be overly coercive and
forcing people into predefined social roles.
Shouldn't individuals be free to choose for themselves their own plans of life
wherever it may take them?
But however that may be a Plato believes he is found in the formula of one man,
one job,
a certain foundation for political justice.
That is to say the three parts of the cities workers auxiliary is guardians.
Each of them all work together and each by minding their own business that is
doing their own job.
Uh,
out of this,
a certain kind of peace and harmony will prevail.
And since the city you remember is simply the sole writ large,
the three classes of the city merely expressed the three parts of the soul.
The soul is just,
he tells us when the appetites spiritedness in reason cooperate with reason,
ruling,
spirit and appetite.
Just as in the Polis,
the philosopher,
king rules,
the warriors and the workers,
the result he tells us as a kind of balance of the parts of the whole right
justice as a kind of harmony in which the three parts of the city and the three
of the soul are direct expressions of one another.
Yeah.
But that formula
forces us to return to the original Socratic question about the harmony of the
soul on the city.
Is the structure of a city identical to the structure of a soul?
Are they really identical?
Well,
maybe,
maybe not.
For example,
every individual consists of three parts of appetite,
spirit and reason.
Yet each of us will be confined.
It seems to only one task,
uh,
in the social hierarchy.
I assume what Socrates means by that is though each individual will,
each of us embody off three features of soul,
appetite,
Spirit,
and reason.
Only one of these will be the dominant trait in each of us.
Some of us will be dominantly appetitive,
uh,
personalities.
Others will be dominantly spirited and so on.
But even still,
when we think of it,
if I am a member of the money making class,
I am still more than simply a bundle of desires and appetites.
Just as a member of the warrior class would be clearly more than than,
than,
than mere through most are mere spiritedness.
So to confine the individual,
it seems to one and only one sphere of life would seem to do an injustice to the
internal psychological complexity that makes each of us who we are.
Let's examine that problem from a slightly different point of view.
Socrates tells us repeatedly the justice in the city consists of each member,
each citizen fulfilling his task in this social division of labor,
in the social hierarchy.
But this seems to be a very far cry,
does it not from the kind of justice he talks about in the soul,
that consists in what we might think of as a sort of rational autonomy or self
control,
where reason controls the passions and the appetites.
In fact,
the vast majority of citizens in even the platonically just city,
well not necessarily have platonically just souls.
Uh,
the harmony and self discipline of the city will not be do it seems to each and
every member of the city.
But rather we'll rely on the Guardian class,
that special class of philosopher kings who will rule,
let it be recalled to selective lies,
myths,
and various kinds of deception.
So how can it be the case,
uh,
if at all that,
you could have a just city,
uh,
that is to say a city where everyone is performing their own tasks,
they're following the division of labor.
And yet very few of those members will have so to speak,
platonically just souls.
That is to say souls dominated by a kind of self control or self guardianship.
Uh,
that will certainly not be true of the members of the,
uh,
artisan class or the,
or the,
or the military class for that,
for that reason.
So the question that question is posed,
that objection is posed by adding Magis.
You remember at the beginning of book four,
what would your apology be?
Socrates.
Eddie Mantra says,
if it were objected that you're hardly making these men happy.
These people just,
he says it.
Forum 19 a Eddie mantises concerned that Socrates is being unfair to the
auxiliaries and the guardians,
giving them all the responsibilities,
but none of the rewards,
none of the pleasures that would seem to be the reward of responsibility.
How can a citizen of Calypso Alice leave,
adjust or happy life if he or she is deprived of most of the goods or pleasures
that we seek?
Socrates gives rather lame response in founding the city.
He says we are not looking to the exceptional happiness of any one individual or
any group,
but rather to the city as a whole.
And Eddie and Mantas appears to accept that response.
Oh yes,
we,
I forgot,
I forgot.
We are concerned with the happiness,
the justice of the hole,
but his question is still is one that lingers and one that played out includes
for a purpose.
What about how can you have a platonically just city if there are most even most
people in it are.
Certainly most people have the auxiliary class are deprived of the pleasures and
the goods that uh,
that we,
that we desire.
It's a question that lingers and one might wonder whether Socrates ever
successfully answers that question.
He silences adding Amanda's in some way as he silences.
There's simic is earlier.
That is not always to say that their objections have been answered and that
leads as it were to the third and final wave of paradox of the [inaudible],
which is the famous proposal for the philosopher King.
What is Plato without the philosopher King?
Yes.
What is the republic without the philosopher King?
Unless the philosophers rule as kings are those now called King's genuinely
philosophize.
There will be no rest from the ILS for the cities.
He says,
right.
Socrates presents this proposal.
Again,
it's outlandish.
She says he expects to be drowned in laughter and this has led some readers to
suggest that the proposal for philosophers,
kings is ironical that it is intended as a kind of joke too in many ways just
credit the idea of the justice city or at least to limp to indicate it's extreme
implausibility.
Yeah.
The question is,
why does Socrates regard philosophic kingship as required for [inaudible] for
the just city?
Let me say,
I am by no means convinced that the idea for the philosopher king is an
impossibility or is intended as a kind of absurdity.
Plato himself remember made a number of trips to Sicily to serve as the advisor
to a king there,
Dionysius and all this.
Although these missions failed and left him deeply dispirited,
the ambition in some ways to unite philosophy and politics has been a recurring
dream of political philosophy ever since Plato.
Socrates says he will be drowned in laughter,
but many other people have taken this dream or this aspiration very seriously.
Consider one thinker and I will.
I'm going to read you a short passage and I'm going to come back to this again
later in the semester from Thomas Hobbes Leviathan,
chapter 31 of Leviathan,
which hubs gives us a very personal statement about his intention in writing
this book.
Hobbs wrote,
I am at the point of believing that my labors will be as useless as the
Commonwealth of Plato.
He seems to be rather despairing about whether this book is actually going to
have any effect.
I'm in the point of believing that it will be as useless as the Commonwealth of
Plato for he also is of the opinion that it is impossible for the disorders of
state and change of government by civil war ever to be taken away till
sovereigns,
the philosophers.
But after admitting his despair about the possibility of realizing his ideas and
practice how Hobbs continues as follows,
I recover some hope.
He says,
uh,
that one time or other in this writing of mine may still fall into the hands of
a sovereign who will consider himself without the help of any interested or
envious interpreter.
And by the exercise of entire sovereignty in protecting the public teaching of
it,
convert this truth of speculation into the utility of practice.
So they are there.
You have hubs talking about his own book expecting or at least hoping it will
fall into the hands of a sovereign who one day again with without a envious or a
self interested interpreters.
May it may one day become a practical source of guidance for statecraft.
Here is Hobbes taking Plato's suggestion very seriously,
and we see this would see this again very much in the history of political
philosophy and thinkers like Rousseau or marks or nature or certain Machiavelli,
all of whom sought to get,
gain the ear of political leaders and convert their ideas into some kind of
practice.
But most of the objections to Plato's particular form of the philosophy,
philosophic kingship,
uh,
really are centered on the practicality.
Uh,
if his idea and beyond this,
there is the problem with the very cogency of the idea itself can consider the
following,
can,
can philosophy and politics actually be United,
it would seem that the needs of philosophy are quite different from the demands
or requirements of political rule.
Can you imagine Socrates willingly giving up one of his conversations for the
tedious business of legislation and public administration?
Can one imagine that the philosopher is described by Plato,
is someone with knowledge of the eternal forms lying behind or beyond the many
particulars,
but just how does that kind of knowledge help us deal with the constant ebb and
flow of political life?
It seems not enough that the philosopher have knowledge of the forms,
but this knowledge has to be supplemented by experience,
by judgment,
and by a kind of practical rationality was played out simply unaware of this.
I can't believe that.
Uh,
I don't believe that.
So the question is,
uh,
what kind of unity was he expecting of philosophy and politics?
Anyway,
philosophers are not purely thinking machines,
uh,
but they are also human beings composed of reason.
Spiritedness and appetite will not even philosophers.
One might ask,
given the possibility of absolute power,
be tempted to abuse their positions.
Maybe,
maybe not.
Who knows?
So these are the questions.
These are,
at least,
these are among the questions that Socrates or Plato,
Plato,
the author of the book,
deliberately poses for us to consider.
So what is the doctrine of the philosopher king intended to prove,
uh,
must a massive effort to construct the city and speech in order to understand
justice in the soul?
It is it a philosophical possibility cause he hauled it out as a,
is a real possibility or must it be considered a failure in some way or that if
the dialogue does end in failure,
what,
what can we learn from that?
Uh,
those are questions I want you to consider,
but for now what I want to do is talk about Plato's democracy and hours.
What does played out teach us about our own regime?
Okay.
Could play Doh have imagined such a regime?
I think in many ways he can and he did
in one sense,
the republic,
and I've given some indications of this today seems to be the most
anti-democratic book ever written.
It's defensive.
Philosophic kingship is itself a direct repudiation of Athenian democracy is
conception of justice.
Minding one's own business is a rejection of the democratic belief that citizens
have sufficient knowledge to participate in the offices of government
to be sure Athenian democracy is not American democracy.
Plato thought of democracy as a kind of rule by the many that he associated with
the unrestricted freedom to do everything that one likes.
This seems in many ways to be quite far from the American democracy based on
constitutional government systems of checks and balances,
protection of individual rights and so on.
The differences between Athens and Washington seemed to be very far and yet in
many ways,
uh,
Socrates a diagnosis,
very powerfully,
uh,
an important condition,
of modern democratic life with which we are all familiar.
Consider this passage in book eight of the Republic,
uh,
that I encourage you to read but uh,
is not on your,
uh,
assigned list.
Uh,
Socrates Wright's book eight,
five 61.
See,
speaking of the democratic soul,
the democratic man,
he also lives along day by day gratifying the desire that occurs to him at one
time drinking and listening to the flute
today we will,
we have different kinds of music to substitute for the flute.
But,
uh,
you get the point drinking and listening to the flute.
It another time,
downing water and dieting now practicing gymnastics and again,
idling and neglecting everything.
And sometimes spending his time as though he were occupied with philosophizing.
Often he engages in politics and jumping up says,
and does whatever chances to come to his mind.
And if he ever admires any soldiers,
he turns in that direction.
And if an end,
if moneymakers in that one,
and there is neither order nor necessity in this life,
but calling this life sweet,
free and blessed,
he follows it throughout
is that is that image of life at all familiar to us?
Uh,
doing anything you like?
it seems to be the opposite of the platonic understanding of justice as each one
doing a special function or fulfilling or are doing a special craft.
Just doing whatever you like and calling that sweet free and blessed throughout
this account should be instantly recognizable as the state of modern democracy
in some ways and they're there exists is Plato and Socrates clearly understand
the very real and tendency within democracy to identify the good human being,
the good man with you might say the good sport,
the regular guy,
the cooperative fellow,
you know someone who goes along and gets along with others by educating citizens
to cooperate with each other in a friendly manner.
Democracies same,
so Plato is suggesting a,
they stand in danger of devaluing people who are prepared to stand alone of
rugged individualists who will go down with the ship if need be.
It is precisely this kind of creeping conformism.
This kind of easy going toleration is sort of soft nihilism that democracies
tend to foster and which not only Plato,
but modern thinkers like Emerson and Tocqueville and mill John Stuart Mill,
very much warned about
what bothers Socrates most about our democracy is a certain kind of instability.
Its tendency to be pulled between extremes of anarchy between lawlessness and
tyranny.
It is this,
it is in this section of the Republican Adyen.
Manchus asks,
won't we?
Won't we with escalas say,
say whatever comes to our lips,
what we say with Escalas,
whatever comes to our lips.
The idea of having the liberty to say whatever comes to our lips sounds to Plato
like a kind of blasphemy.
The view that nothing is shameful,
that ev,
everything should be permitted to say whatever comes to our lips.
There was a kind of license that comes from the denial of any restraints on our
desires or kind of relativistic belief that our desires are equal and all should
be permitted.
Yeah.
Plato's view some democracy.
We're not all negative to be sure.
He wasn't only a critic of democracy.
It was after all a democracy that produced Socrates and allowed him to
philosophize freely until his 70th year.
Would this have been permitted in any other city of the ancient world and he
surely would not be allowed to philosophize in many cities and countries today.
Okay.
You remember the letter that Plato wrote near the end of his life when he
compares the democracy to a golden age,
at least in comparison to what went after Plato here seems to agree with Winston
Churchill that democracy is the worst regime except for all the others.
Okay.
So worst,
it's been tried except for everything else.
So what is,
what is the function of colonialists this perfect,
this beautiful city?
What,
what purpose does it serve?
The philosopher King,
he tells us,
may be an object of hope or wish,
but Plato realizes that this possibility is not really to be expected
if the philosophic city is introduced as a metaphor to help us understand the
education of the soul.
The reform of politics may not be within our power,
but the exercise of self control always is the first responsibility of the
individual who wishes to engage in political reform is to reform themselves
or reform seems to begin at home.
And we all see this,
uh,
very vividly when we look at so many politicians today and public Scholes who
teach us and how,
who are hectoring us about living a certain way of life,
living a certain living according to their lights.
Uh,
and then we will find out of course,
something very shameful about them.
I won't you,
I,
I'm thinking of a couple of,
of people in particular won't mention any,
any names in the,
in the public sphere.
Plato's judgment seems to be you,
you need to reform yourself before you can,
uh,
think about reforming,
others.
Uh,
this is a point that is often lost in the republic that it is first of all,
uh,
work on the reform of the soul.
That is not to say at all that it teaches withdrawal from political
responsibilities.
It does not philosophy.
And certainly Socratic philosophy requires friends,
comrades,
conversations.
It is not something that can simply be pursued in isolation.
Socrates understands that those who want to reform others must reform
themselves,
but many who've tried to imitate him have been less careful.
It is easy to confuse as many people have done.
The Republic with a recipe for tyranny,
the 20th century,
and even the beginnings of our own,
uh,
is littered with the corpses of those who have set themselves up as philosopher,
kings,
Lenin,
Stalin,
Hitler,
Mao Khomeini to name just some of the most obvious.
But these men are not philosophers.
They're professions to justice are just that.
They are professions are pretentions expressing their vanity and their ambition
for Plato.
Philosophy was in the first instance,
a therapy for our passions in a way of setting limits to our desires.
And this is precisely the opposite of the tyrant who played oh describes as a
person of limitless desires who lacks the most rudimentary kind of governance,
namely self control.
The difference between the philosopher and the tyrant illustrate two very
different conceptions of philosophy.
For some philosophy represents a form of liberation from confusion,
from unruly passions and prejudices from incoherence.
Again,
a therapy of the soul that brings peace and contentment and just end to kind of
justice.
And yet for others,
philosophy is the source of the desire to dominate.
It is the basis of tyranny and the great age of ideologies through which we are
still passing.
The question is that both tendencies or at work within philosophy,
and how do we encourage one side but not the other?
Is that great philosopher Karl Marx once asked,
who will educate the educators?
So why is this thing he ever said?
Who will educate the educators who do turn to for help?
There was obviously no magic solution to this question,
but the best answer I know of is Socrates.
He showed people how to live and just as importantly,
he showed them how to die.
He lived and died.
Not like most people,
but better,
and even his most vehement critics will admit to that.
Yeah,
thank you very much.
I'll see you next Wednesday and we'll start Aristotle.